I was fun I had a good time being
terminated again and doing you know the
role kind of a little bit differently
than the other ones but to play kind of
like multiple characters to play one
Terminator that is still the destructive
machine and that is really out to
destroy the human race and to protect
the machines and then there's the other
one which is also a t800 model that is
there to predict Sarah Connor
and to predict the human race so that is
of course the big conflict there between
the two and that creates then this big
epic battle the writers have explained
it best pitch is saying that they're not
trying to eliminate of what has done
have been done in the past it's just
basically keeping everything intact but
then adding on and showing another
scenario
he's what happens in 1984 terminator
comes back to find Sarah Connor but as
he collects his clothes from those punks
there's another there's a voice behind
it it says you won't need the clothes
and from that point on hell breaks loose
because the other Terminator over
certain
is there and then they have this huge
battle so it didn't goes into a
different direction where the time
travel is different the the various
different timelines are different so
it's really very smartly crafted and
people are really surprised and even
James Cameron said that if I would have
thought if he would have done another
terminator that's the direction he would
have gone it's a really interesting
thing that what they did with Terminator
with the Genesis because they have used
of the real action as much as you can so
that was the order stunts were done we
were flying through the air and we were
suspended on harnesses we were taken you
know off the ramps and they exploding
out in the day and flying through the
air and landing and
they're jumping off the helicopter and
off the stuff was real stuff and then
also with some people that when he got
very dangerous
some people jumped in and did some of
the work but then because of the
technology that is available that then
added the technology the CGI and then
made the storytelling much more complete
so it's a combination of the ultimate of
technology and also using the
old-fashioned way like remember that the
for instance the the bus flipping
through the air well you know I've never
ever seen a huge bus flipped deadeyes
through the air but it was done with the
Rams with explosive explosives with
through cables and with all kinds of
means to get that bus flying through the
air and twisting in air and then
crashing down and sliding and it was
basically nothing on a golden gate
bridge the way it is in the film but it
was done on a regular street that was
created specifically in Louisiana in New
Orleans right near the studio where we
filmed and they prepped this whole thing
and they created exactly the same amount
of lanes and they created you know the
cast that usually at any given time
during the day are on that Gordon Gate
Bridge and then they created this may
Hanlon table be the bouncer with the bus
flying and going through this the chase
scene and all his stuff and what effect
and the terminator the t 1500 has on
this bus well it was interesting for me
to fight myself because they were very
smartly hiring a bodybuilder there was
kind of a mr. universe physique he had
and also stuntmen so he was really good
with the fight scenes and he was you
know had the party that 20-30 years ago
you wouldn't have found but now there's
a lot of stunt guys and a lot of people
that have parties like that because
they've trained really hard and
technology is available with the
machines and the training and orders and
this guy was a competitive bodybuilder
and so he was doing this fight scene
with me and the idea was that there was
me from 1984 and so to me the whole time
was always the question
are they gonna do the face replacement
how to do the head replacement how did
they do the changing of the body because
he has the Mr Universe physique but it
wasn't exactly the same body I have
because everybody is different so you
know so they did with technology again a
really great job in in making it all
possible besides the great fight scenes
and battles the futuristic war and the
chase in order self to me the the story
itself and the emotional rollercoaster
ride I think is going to be the most
powerful thing in a movie
you